Who among us hasn’t wondered what happens
after our lives have come to their inevitable
ending, and we play out our final moments
in the land of the living?
The concept of what happens to us after we’ve
died has baffled scientists and philosophers
the world over for almost as long as human
civilization has existed.
Some out there already claim to know the exact
answer.
You probably already know that the belief
in the existence of an afterlife is one held
by almost every single religion and culture
around the globe; Heaven, Hell, Valhalla,
Purgatory, Limbo, Sheol, the World to Come.
Descriptions of the afterlife, and how to
get sent there, often varies depending on
the religion or cultural group it is linked
to.
But to think in more general terms, the concept
usually revolves around the soul leaving the
body after death, and living forever in eternal
paradise.
That is, of course, unless you’ve committed
any deadly sins during your lifetime.
If the myths are to be believed, these normally
result in you being sent down to spend eternity
in damnation and endless punishment instead
of paradise.
Sadly, there’s no way to prove if any of
the various afterlives actually exist.
By their very nature, these afterlives exist
separate from the real, physical world that
we live in while we are still alive.
While we’re here on Earth, we can only observe
what we see happening to a body after death,
and what we assume or believe the afterlife
might be like.
After all, it’s not like any deceased person
can tell us what being dead is like… well,
not under the normal circumstances anyway.
With no proof of the afterlife’s existence,
we do unfortunately get left with the bleak
and existentially terrifying assumption that,
when we die, there is nothing waiting for
us on the other side.
What if there’s no light at the end of the
tunnel, no pearly gates, just… nothing,
forever?
But what if someone, or some mysterious group
of persons, already knew the answer to what
happened after the end of all human life?
And what if the answer was so much more horrifying
than we ever could have imagined, so much
so that this shadowy cabal had already tried
to prevent the fate awaiting all of us after
we die?
Be warned, we’re about to delve into the
unsettling tale of something known as Project
Dammerung, and its connection to something
known as SCP-3448, as the Foundation categorizes
it.
It’s a story about our fear of what comes
next, beyond this mortal coil.
This is the catalyst for the Foundation uncovering
the most horrific secret in human history,
a truth that should have stayed buried.
Warning - We are about to unravel the beginning
of the end.
“The end of what?”
you might be asking.
Why, the End of Death itself, of course.
Any outsider looking in might think we’re
being a little bit over-dramatic here, but
we’ll forgive you for that mistake, you
can have that one on us.
At first glance, to the untrained eye and
uninformed individual, SCP-3448 might just
seem like little more than a Magnetic Resonance
Imaging machine, or an MRI for short.
Chances are you’ve seen these big machines
in medical dramas, or maybe you’ve even
been placed inside one during a stay at the
hospital.
Using powerful magnets, an MRI machine aligns
all the protons in your body.
Then, the machine generates a pulse of radiofrequency
current to create a detailed image of the
inside of a patient’s body.
Basically, to put it in extremely oversimplified
terms, it’s a big camera for looking at
your internal organs.
Now, don’t forget to smile, really show
off that pancreas, it looks great at this
angle!
Of course, when dealing with anomalies encountered
by the SCP Foundation, few things are ever
really exactly as they first seem.
And in that very same vein, SCP-3448 is far
more than just a harmless piece of medical
apparatus.
Look beyond the main bulk of the MRI machine
and you’ll start to notice that a few unique
modifications have been made to the device.
For one, the winding mass of jumper cables
connecting the machine to its rudimentary
upgrades, namely the same type of technology
used in particle accelerators, along with
a whole collection of custom circuit boards.
For another, although you wouldn’t know
just from looking at SCP-3448, the contraption
has also been through a number of anomalous
rituals, seemingly combining the technological
with the occult and spiritual.
But the question remains: why?
What is this thing for exactly?
To put it simply, it’s a hotline to the
great beyond.
SCP-3448 is a means of communication with
the world of the dead themselves.
Now, we might be oversimplifying things yet
again there, so let’s take it from the top.
Project Dammerung was the name given to those
who developed SCP-3448.
That designation doesn’t just refer to the
modified MRI machine itself, but also the
communication that said device was capable
of after the Project Dammerung team had finished
their tinkering with it.
You see, nobody knows what happens to us after
we die, because no one has ever been able
to experience being dead in the real world
and existing in the afterlife at the same
time.
But with SCP-3448, that problem just simply
isn’t an issue anymore.
Still with us so far?
Okay, here’s how the machine actually works.
A living human is placed inside, just like
those ordinary MRI machines at your local
hospital.
However, the difference here is that the extra,
anomalous components of SCP-3448 – the rituals,
the particle acceleration, and so on – allow
this person to enter a unique state of being
halfway between life and death.
Their bodily functions are halted, brought
to a stop by the machine.
However, they are still able to retain their
consciousness and the awareness that this
allows for.
Not quite dead, but not quite alive either,
sort of an ‘unalive’ state or a half-death,
if you prefer.
Or perhaps...Halfterlife.
Now, while a person is in this half-death,
they will have entered a conceptual state
of being.
This is referred to as SCP-3448-A, an existence
of pure consciousness while physical form,
in this case, the person’s body, exists
separately in the real world.
The body, now called SCP-3448-1, no longer
houses a subject’s consciousness, their
essence.
Not just their mind but their thoughts and
personality.
If it helps to think of it in theological
terms, you could even think of it as their
soul.
But, while the machine’s function is all
very impressive and interesting, what’s
the actual point to it?
Why spend so much time trying to create a
controlled separation of consciousness from
a dead body?
What’s Project Dammerung for?
Well, that’s easy.
SCP-3448 is the primary tool intended to complete
the sole objective of Project Dammerung, a
mission to capture a dangerous cognitohazard:
namely, death itself.
To be clear, when we say “death”, we don’t
mean the Grim Reaper, that skull-faced, scythe-wielding
embodiment of oblivion.
Chances are, you can probably catch him just
by going out on Halloween with a big net.
But Project Dammerung’s goal was to contain
the actual process of death, the very concept
that takes a living, conscious entity and
makes it the opposite.
You see, when a living subject is placed in
SCP-3448 and their consciousness leaves their
brain, it leaves behind some kind of anomalous
electrical energy signature.
As you may already know if you can remember
back to high school Biology class, the brain
uses electrical impulses to send signals all
over the body, allowing your organs to function,
your limbs to move, and your muscles to contract
or relax.
What’s strange is, this electrical activity
seems to continue within the brain of someone
whose consciousness has been separated from
their body by SCP-3448.
Studying these signals, the SCP Foundation
personnel working on Project Dammerung have
inferred that these are residual signals,
replicating how the brain would react if the
subject introduced into the half-dead SCP-3448-1
state as if they were still alive, even though
they have to be dead in order to access that
state in the first place.
And now your brain is probably such a mess
of electrical signals trying to keep up with
all that, that you might have completely missed
the part where we told you that Project Dammerung
is actually a Foundation-backed project.
Okay, let’s have a speedy recap.
So far, we have an anomalously modified MRI
machine, capable of splitting the consciousness,
or soul, of a person after rendering them
clinically dead.
On top of that, the Foundation themselves
sanctioned the project that created this device
in an effort to capture and contain death
itself.
But, how did this come about?
Who among the SCP Foundation would want to
contain death, so much to commission an entire
project dedicated to that goal?
Well, who do we all know sitting above the
entire Foundation, overseeing everything,
infamous for all having some anomalous form
of immortality, and would stand to gain from
Project Dammerung?
That’s right, the world championship death
dodgers: The O5 Council.
You see, in order to more fully understand
why Project Dammerung was established, and
why they built SCP-3448, we need to explain
a little bit about a different anomaly: SCP-2718.
We have another video on this channel that
goes into more detail about that, but to put
it in a nutshell, SCP-2718 is the horrible
truth about what happens to us after we die.
The O5 Council first learned of it when one
of their own, O5-11, full name Roger Sheldon,
died of a stroke.
O5-11 was the only council member to have
refused to accept any of the anomalous treatments
or enhancements that prevented the other O5s
from dying.
However, the council chose to resurrect him.
Upon his return to the land of the living,
Roger Sheldon told the other overseers what
he had learned about the nature of the afterlife,
what lies beyond this fleeting mortal coil,
waiting for us after we die.
Roger had experienced firsthand that the dead
actually remain conscious after their bodies
have shut down all other functions.
That meant that everyone, every person to
have died over the course of human history,
has remained aware of everything that happened
to them afterward.
They can feel themselves slowly decaying,
their bones and skin withering, buried under
the cold, wasting away into nothingness day
after day.
And that’s SCP-2718, the painful truth that
there is no paradise, no heaven, no afterlife.
There is just endless, silent consciousness
beyond the end of every life.
This revelation is what instigated the overseer
council, specifically O5-4, to establish Project
Dammerung.
It was learning the answer to ‘what happens
next’ that spurred the creation of SCP-3448.
The intention was, by reading and interacting
with those residual electrical signals in
the brain, that the Foundation could create
a link, a form of two-way communication between
them in the living world and the subject,
SCP-3448-A, in their half-dead state.
Using other items’ anomalous technology
connected to the MRI machine, the Foundation’s
researchers could interpret the electrical
signals in SCP-3448-A’s brain as images.
A Foundation agent by the name of Anthony
Michaels proved to be the only test subject
capable of using SCP-3448, beyond the earliest
tests on animal specimens.
And we know what you’re thinking, the Foundation
would normally use D-Class personnel for this
sort of test.
After all, it’s a machine that renders you
almost dead, stopping all bodily function.
The problem was, Project Dammerung needed
someone loyal to the Foundation, and D-Classes
could hardly be trusted to follow orders without
the threat of death.
Think about it, you separate their consciousness
from their body and they don’t care if you
threaten to kill them.
Agent Michaels served as the SCP-3448-A component,
residing within the modified MRI machine,
held in a state between life and death.
But something went wrong, something that would
ultimately do more harm than good.
The Foundation had tried in vain to contain
death, and in tampering with forces well beyond
their own understanding, may have accidentally
done something even worse.
They neutralised it.
They killed death, and things only went downhill
from there...
Now go check out “Evil Monster Created by
SCP Foundation SCP-2419 - The Laughing Men”
and “SCP-006 - Fountain of Youth” for
more SCPs that blur the line between life
and death!